cuando era niño
estudiaba en una escuela unidocente
una escuela que estaba en una zona rural
y recuerdo que en toda la escuela
éramos únicamente 12 estudiantes
allí en una pequeña biblioteca una
biblioteca que no eran más que tres
estantes
encontré un libro que hablaba acerca de
fusión nuclear y que es justamente el
libro que ustedes están viendo en esta
imagen
entre jugar fútbol
e ir a la escuela además de subirme en
los palos de guayaba
dedicado a mi tiempo libre a plantear
mis ideas acerca de las reacciones de
fusión
me preguntaba en ese entonces qué pasaba
cuando un núcleo cargado positivamente
de un átomo chocaba con otro
y empezaba a escribir
mis teorías mis ideas que ustedes
también pueden ver en esta imagen
esto lo hacía cuando cuando estaba en la
escuela y un día según yo
llegué a diseñar
un cohete propulsado por fusión nuclear
fue a partir de eso que me di cuenta que
mi destino sería llegar al ser
científico de fusión
y más que eso dedicar mi vida entera a
la búsqueda de una nueva fuente de
energía como seres humanos tenemos un
gran reto
y es desarrollar una fuente de energía
que supla todas nuestras demandas una
fuente de energía que sea inagotable que
sea limpia que sea segura que nos
permita iluminar nuestras ciudades
utilizando combustibles fósiles que nos
permita suplir de energía nuestro
transporte sin generar contaminación esa
fuente de energía es la que vengo a
contarles hoy y en la cual costa rica
realiza investigación esa fuente de
energía es la energía de las estrellas
hay una cosa que tiene que preocuparnos
mucho
y es que conforme pasan los años
más y más energía necesitamos pero lo
interesante es que las proyecciones nos
dicen que cada vez vamos a estar
en peor capacidad de producir energía
y porque eso es así bueno porque
justamente el petróleo y el carbón se
nos van a ir acabando
y ustedes saben que es a partir de
fuentes de combustibles fósiles que el
mundo entero está alimentando su demanda
de energía
eso nos lleva a un punto muy muy serio
que tenemos que reconocer y es que la
brecha energética entre lo que
consumimos y lo que producimos cada vez
se va a ir ampliando más y más
como científico tengo una gran
responsabilidad de hacer investigación
para buscar una solución a este problema
y es justamente lo que realizo en mi día
a día
ustedes saben que en el universo hay
miles de millones de estrellas
y todas ellas están de manera continua
produciendo grandes cantidades de
energía podrían ustedes por un momento
imaginarse lo que sería si lográramos en
la tierra reproducir las condiciones
como las estrellas generan su energía
tendríamos una fuente inagotable
que nos permitiría resolver de una vez
por todas nuestra demanda creciente de
energía
para explicarles cómo se podría lograr
eso
les voy a contar que el proceso que se
da en las estrellas se conoce como
fusión nuclear
y esto tratando de decirlo en palabras
simples no es más que tomar átomos
ligeros como por ejemplo el hidrógeno
y lograr que se junten para que en ese
proceso se libere una gran cantidad de
energía es decir nuestro sol la materia
prima de nuestro sol es el hidrógeno
la materia prima de las estrellas es el
hidrógeno
y es el elemento más abundante en
nuestro universo
entonces la función es el proceso que
gobierna
la generación de energía en las
estrellas pero por otro lado tenemos un
proceso contrario llamado fisión que es
cuando el átomo o el núcleo se parte en
dos y también se libera una gran
cantidad de energía contarles que ese es
el proceso que se da en los reactores
nucleares actuales
pero tiene algunos inconvenientes que
ustedes habrán oído
se libera radiación que es dañina para
el ser humano
pero quiero dejarles claro en esta
diapositiva de que la función no genera
radiación dañina
la función no tiene posibilidad de
explotar no podemos ver un fukushima y
chernóbil en un reactor de fusión
si hiciéramos una comparación tal vez
ustedes estarán preguntando qué tanta
energía se puede generar confusión
comparada a otras
comparemos la afición con la energía
química se logra 64 mil veces más
energía
pero si comparamos un posible reactor de
fusión con una fuente química se
producen 10 millones de veces más
energía
eso nos lleva entonces a poner el
ejemplo que ustedes observan aquí con
solo 25 gramos un reactor de fusión le
daría la energía que necesitan estos dos
niños en toda su vida
con solo 25 gramos
y si hiciéramos un ejercicio pensáramos
por un momento en costa rica construir
una planta de mil megawatts
será claro que si la hacemos de carbón
necesitaríamos grandes volúmenes de este
material y si lo hiciéramos con petróleo
de igual manera pero lo interesante es
que si en costa rica llegáramos a
construir una planta de mil megawatts
la materia prima que necesitaríamos la
podríamos colocar en una furgoneta
hay una cosa que debe de estar en
nuestras mentes constantemente y es que
el petróleo se nos va a acabar el carbón
se nos va a acabar
pero tengamos presentes que si el ser
humano llega a desarrollar la energía de
fusión
tendremos energía por billones de años
decimos que la fusión es una fuente
universal justamente por lo que les
mencionaba antes todas las estrellas
producen su energía a partir de este
proceso uno podría pensar
y así le diría el sentido común que el
ser humano debería estar produciéndose
energía también por fusión
es una fuente que será segura porque no
tiene posibilidad de explotar
no existe la posibilidad de una reacción
en cadena
es una fuente amigable con el ambiente
justamente los pocos volúmenes de
materia prima que necesitamos para
generar grandes cantidades de energía
nos llevará a conservar el planeta de
mejor manera además de que no genera
gases de efecto invernadero
decimos que es internacional la energía
de fusión porque nos va a ayudar a
resolver conflictos entre países
justamente que compiten por los recursos
naturales cada país estaría en la
capacidad de generar su energía de
manera completamente local sin depender
de las fuentes de recursos naturales de
otros países
y decimos que es inagotable y justamente
esto tiene relación con lo que les decía
antes el combustible es el hidrógeno
el elemento más abundante del universo y
como digo siempre si las estrellas no lo
han agotado menos el ser humano lo va a
agotar
tiene la capacidad de una escala
industrial porque con un reactor de
fusión se podría producir la energía
de toda una ciudad por 24 horas
y desde luego para nosotros los
científicos es emocionante y debe de
serlo para todos los seres humanos
porque a partir de los grandes proyectos
científicos y tecnológicos es que el ser
humano progresa
el desarrollo de investigación en fusión
ha dado origen a grandes progresos
y si usted se está preguntando si esto
es alcanzable pues tengo que contarle
que ya lo logramos en la tierra ya hemos
logrado producir reacciones de fusión y
el trabajo que hacemos los científicos
es justamente para ir perfeccionando esa
tecnología para que un día llegue al ser
la principal fuente para producir
electricidad que tenga el ser humano
y definitivamente definitivamente esta
será la fuente del futuro porque va a
venir a revolucionar por completo va a
transformar por completo la forma como
el ser humano produce su energía
para lograr la función podemos hacerlo
varias formas una es con gravedad
claramente nosotros en la tierra no lo
podemos hacer lo podemos lograr a través
de campos magnéticos cuando usted pegas
un souvenir en la refrigeradora ahí hay
una fuerza magnética es justamente esa
la que la que tenemos que utilizar y
entonces vamos a atrapar lo que se llama
plasma que es el cuarto estado de la
materia cuando llueve y gerard quería en
costa rica tenemos un espectáculo de
plasma los rayos son plasma y entonces
ese plasma lo atrapamos con ese campo
magnético y empieza a dar vueltas y
vueltas y vueltas en un dispositivo que
tiene esta forma que ustedes observan
aquí
donde los círculos verdes corresponden a
bobinas que generan el campo magnético y
ese plasma lo llevamos a 150 millones de
grados es decir 10 veces la temperatura
del centro del sol y entonces si usted
se preguntará cuáles son los
dispositivos más investigados en el
mundo tengo que contarle que existen dos
que voy a mencionar los nombres tokamak
y esther vector
y usted dirá bueno esto está un poco
lejos de costa rica pues no costa rica
no sólo tiene un este director no sólo
tiene un tokamak costa rica tiene los
dos y contarles que él este lector que
tenemos aquí
cataloga a costa rica como uno de los
únicos seis países en el mundo que tiene
esta tecnología y por si fuera poco
entonces usted se puede preguntar cuáles
instituciones en el mundo tendrán de los
dos tipos bueno decirle que únicamente
tres instituciones en el mundo tienen un
toca mango esférico y tienen un estéril
editor para investigar fusión nuclear
esto nos tiene que llenar de mucho
orgullo y como mencionaron en la
presentación costa rica hoy es parte del
consejo internacional de investigación
en fusión el mayor consejo científico en
esta área
finalmente contarles que el mayor
proyecto científico que construye 35
países es llamado éter que encenderán su
primer plasma en el 2025 es uno de los
mayores proyectos científicos de la
humanidad hoy en día
y si usted se pregunta si hemos logrado
progreso pues aquí les comparó el
progreso del desarrollo de
microprocesadores con el progreso de la
tecnología de fusión vamos al mismo
ritmo así como se desarrollan las
computadoras se desarrolla la tecnología
de fusión
y llegaremos con eso definitivamente a
tener reactores de fusión que atrapen a
ese sol que lo confinen y que nos
permitan suministrar esa energía
eléctrica que nuestra demanda nos pide
creo definitivamente en un mejor mañana
un mañana donde el ser humano pueda
producir su energía de una manera limpia
segura e inagotable como lo hacen las
estrellas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]